quentin du jardin bonsoir merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
ce soir dans quel état d'esprit ce que
vous êtes au lendemain de l'intervention
des forces de l'ordre dans cette église
alors que vous étiez en plein concert
triste en raison d'une amende que vous
risquiez découper ou bien heureux parce
que vous avez fait parler de vous et
vous avait alerté sur la détresse que
rencontrent les musiciens et les
artistes
contraint de ne pas travailler en raison
des crises sanitaires alors à cette
heure-ci il est à peu près 8 heures et
midi soir je ne connais toujours pas
vous la décision du procureur du roi
quant à savoir s'il va poursuivre ou pas
la verbalisation dont je suis sujet une
verbalisation de 4000 euros identique
pour la personne qui a ouvert l'église
dont 4000 euros et 250 euros par
personne présente dans ce dans cette
église donc un montant total d'un peu
moins de 12000 euros et j'attends à ce
jour une réponse de la part du parquet
général
donc l'équivalent chez nous du préfet en
france chez notre procureur ne prévient
pas de la verbalisation
c'est sûr que le problème est assez
complexe au niveau juridique et l'acte
qui pourrait bien être qualifiés d'actes
politiques plutôt qu'une interdiction
finalement bravé pour pour un acte de
culture on va dire puisqu'il s'agissait
du d'émerger de faire émerger la
question culturelle au plus haut niveau
ce crime ce qu'on appelle le comité de
conservation et ce comité de
concertation finalement chez nous depuis
à peu près cinq mois d'ici ce planches
il se penche absolument plus sur la
question culturelle un disparu
dans quel état d'esprit est ce que vous
êtes alors est ce que vous êtes triste
parce que du coup il ya tout le côté à
mende où est ce que vous êtes heureux
parce que vous faîtes entendre votre
voix est celle des musiciens qui ne
peuvent exercer
je n'ai aucune crainte quant aux amants
dont je n'ai aucune tristesse parce
qu'il ya des centaines de chant qui sont
prêts à payer et participer à cette
amende éventuelle si elle a bien lieu et
je suis très heureux d'avoir redonné une
fille à quelques spectateurs d'avoir
permis à la culture de d'exister
symboliquement et moi personnellement
at-il personnelle d'avoir pu jouer cinq
minutes avant d'être arrêté par la
police
la tenue
d'études est autorisée en belgique vous
pensiez que la police est là intervenir
vous vous y attendiez vous ne vous y
attendiez pas alors l'action a été
présentée depuis une semaine aux médias
donc évidemment nous avons communiqué en
prévention à l'ensemble de la population
et donc au parquet fédéral qui m'a
contacté deux jours avant la prestation
qu'on me dire monsieur du jardin voici
les amendes que vous encourez parce que
vous souhaitez persister dans votre acte
évidemment pour moi la question était
évidente que oui je crois qu'il est
nécessaire maintenant de deux braves et
on va dire quelque part ces absurdités
qui sont créés par ces arrêtés
ministériels ou circulaire on va dire ça
comme ça chez qui mène en fait à des
situations absurdes
on se sens que un prêtre est bien
autorisé en belgique a officié devant
quinze personnes 15 fidèles messi se
prête et remplacé par un artiste est
bien là la police intervient et nous
sommes verbaliser presque un an de crise
sanitaire
dans quel état d'esprit sont les
artistes
en belgique on vient de paraître de
vodka vous parler d' absurdité
en france il ya eu des victoires de la
musique des artistes comme benjamin
biolay ou jean louis aubert ont appelé
la ministre française de la culture
roselyne bachelot à rouvrir les salles
c'est pareil outre quiévrain
oui bien sûr celle où il ya un silence
qu'il devient très très pesant je dirais
que la précarité s'est mécanisée
mécanisée part c'est par cet état qui
est réellement un état finalement de non
droit par rapport au fait que la
constitution est totalement bafoués et
en réalité pour l'instant on est sur ce
fil tendu de ne plus très bien savoir ce
qui va se passer avec la réouverture ou
pas en tout cas moi mon geste se
limitait profondément a dénoncé cette
question d' absurdité qui apparaît
effectivement de plus en plus prégnante
aussi aux yeux des tribunaux puisqu'il
ya de plus en plus de surcharge de
procès verbaux qui sont dressés et qui
en fait font état de ces absurdités mais
qui sont devenus ingérables au niveau
des tribunaux donc finalement en tant
qu'artiste je pense que c'était de mon
devoir
de ramener cette question culturelle
avec un geste fort avec une action
symbolique qui redonnait peut-être du
sens au combat des artistes parce que
vous savez où d'un moment la question de
d'être entendue à travers des cartes
blanches des écrits dans les journaux
etc ne suffit plus il faut avoir je
pense une action symbolique qui va
frapper un coup on va dire dans un sens
symbolique la table des négociations
gouvernementales pour se faire entendre
et donc c'est bel et bien ici en
belgique
la question de la liberté de culture que
j'ai bel et bien soulever puisque c'est
ce qui n'existe pas inscrit dans notre
constitution nous avons la liberté de
culte comme vous en france la liberté
d'expression la liberté de réunion
mais la liberté de presse évidemment
mais la liberté de culture est quelque
chose que je revendique maintenant
absolument dans l'inscription de la
constitution pour ans ne plus en arriver
à ces 1 considération envers les les
artistes en général et donc évidemment
si les ministres de la culture en france
et en belgique souhaite se coordonner
dans une pensée qui pourrait peut-être
faire évoluer la question je pense que
nous serons sur un chemin positif pour
les artistes
vous avez évoqué canton du genre dans la
précarité qui augmente
du côté des artistes est ce que vous
vous avez encore des rentrées d'argent
et comment vivent la plupart de vos
confrères en ces temps difficiles de
crise
alors moi j'ai ce qu'on appelle je vis
avec l'équivalent de l'intermittence du
spectacle chez vous je suis comme un
intermittent du spectacle j'ai ce statut
artistique qui me permet de vivre avec
1200 euros mais j'ai quatre personnes à
charge
avec évidemment comme beaucoup de
personnes une maison d assurance voilà
une voiture à payer vous rendez bien
compte que le seuil de pauvreté est
largement dépassé et je dirais que le
seuil de l'indécence de ce gouvernement
de ne pas apporter une bouffée d'oxygène
une bouffée d'air ou en tout cas
d'autoriser au minimum un artiste à
pénétrer un lieu culte pour pouvoir
simplement gagner un tout petit peu
dignité et peut-être un tout petit peu
sa vie parce que j'accepte en fait le
chiffre de 15 qui est extrêmement réduit
mais je l'avais évidemment sur cette
journée répercuter sur cinq concerts
d'affilée et se passer de 20 minutes
chacun ce qui me faisait un public de 75
personnes et donc de pouvoir gagner ma
vie décemment si vous faites payer 15 ou
20 euros la place au bout de la journée
vous pouvez dire que vous avez gagné un
salaire correct au vu en tout cas la
destruction de ce secteur de la culture
donc l'action était réellement de
pouvoir aussi dire aux artistes
voilà une brèche engouffré vous le culte
est en solidarité avec les artistes
je pense qu'il est également en france
il ya plusieurs personnes qui se sont
prononcées aussi de ce côté là et
j'espère que cet acte fort va permettre
sur nos pays en tout cas qu'ils pensent
de la même façon dans cette liberté
d'expression qui est tellement cher à la
france chez nous elle est je pense assez
bien amoindrie et la question du silence
à l'heure actuelle de la part du parquet
fédéral m'impressionne quant à peut-être
une volonté d'éteindre la feuille ou en
tout cas de la limite et en douceur
merci canton du jardin d'avoir répondu à
nos questions nous avoir livré votre
témoignage de ce qui s'est donc passé
hier